aside from the obvious impact of
Catherine dying and being pulled into
hell there are a lot of lasting
emotional and physical ramifications
that come from the film's final exorcism
sequence Katherine's parents now will
likely feel a sense of regret and
remorse for not saving their daughter
but they do show signs working toward
being in a better place although the
emotion of that loss is surely crushing
and will have a lasting impact on their
family there's a sense of hope that
comes alongside the arrival of
Katherine's mother as for Victor and an
their faith is restored and mended
Victor now knows that the supernatural
both good and bad exist he visits his
wife's Tombstone to reconnect with the
past he's tried to leave behind now he
and Angela can talk freely about it and
move forward together plus it seems like
Angela can start a new following this
incident but still misses Catherine an
now has a new perspective on herself and
what her faith can achieve maybe this
leads to her trying to be a nun again
potentially leading her to spearhead the
franchise in future installments